i'm mark lata and i create the videos
you see on my channel soft white
underbelly
about a month ago youtube changed their
policy on sex related content on their
platform demonetizing
all the videos that have any kind of
sexual content that impacts about
two-thirds of the videos that are on my
channel
and
impacts my ability to
recoup the expenses that are
considerable in producing this content
100 of the money that i've made on
youtube since i've started has gone back
into the communities that i shoot in 100
of it and that is going to be diminished
greatly by this decision and there's
really not much i can do about it you
know my initial reaction was to put
these videos on my subscription channel
but i realized after doing that for a
few weeks that the reason i'm doing this
project is not to make money the reason
i'm doing it is to help
create some awareness of what's going on
in our country i believe these videos
help society by understanding how and
why these situations come to be what we
can do to raise our kids differently to
protect them from similar fates
i believe it also helps the interviewee
to share their story very often for the
first time
i think that's that's beneficial to the
interviewee it's also helps helps with
uh people who are watching the story
that are going through similar things so
they don't feel so alone
i'm frustrated by this decision by
youtube but it is their platform and
they can do what they like
you know i would think an advertiser
would love to have their ad
on a video that's going to get 200 to
400 000 views it's first day like my sex
related videos get
but uh it's again it's their platform
and they're going to do what they like
if you wanted to support my my channel
financially i guess you could do so by
subscribing to the subscription channel
which is ten dollars a month
you get ad-free versions of all the
videos you'll get
about 200
exclusive videos that are not on youtube
and more to come
and uh the videos are uploaded the night
before when they're uploaded on youtube
you can also make a donation of the
gofundme the general the channel is
general gofundme which is uh
which is uh the link is in the
description and you can just make a
donation to the channel itself if you
wanted to
don't feel any obligation to do any of
these things
this this problem is my problem not
yours these videos are on youtube for
free you can enjoy them don't feel you
don't feel obliged to do anything
it's only if you wanted to
so that's what's going on i'm frustrated
but uh it's a shame that youtube views
my work as pornography instead of
beneficial to society or anyone i'm
interviewing
or the viewers
but that's that's just the way it's
going to be
so everything will be back to normal
you'll be seeing all the content
here on youtube for free and
thank you for watching thank you for
subscribing and
we'll see you
next time thank you